cuando Arabia Saudita e Irán firmaron un
acuerdo para restablecer sus relaciones
diplomáticas las miradas se volcaron
automáticamente hacia yemen muchos veían
ese acercamiento como una posibilidad de
menguar el conflicto que ha devastado al
país de medio oriente durante casi una
década en las calles de sanah la capital
algunos se sienten esperanzados
somos optimistas sobre el acuerdo entre
Irán y Arabia Saudita y Esperamos que
los pueblos árabes vivan en paz Dios
Todopoderoso nosotros los árabes del
Líbano Siria yemen estamos cansados de
Las Guerras queremos la paz desde 2015
yemen se convirtió en lugar de una
guerra indirecta entreherán Arabia
Saudita una de las potencias unitas en
medio oriente se unió a otros Países
Árabes y apoyados por Estados Unidos
Reino Unido y Francia formaron una
coalición que respaldó al gobierno
yemení reconocido internacionalmente
mientras que Irán optó por apoyar a los
Rebeldes su tías la contraparte del
conflicto uno que se escaló rápidamente
por eso limar las entre rivales
regionales ha sido visto como un paso
hacia la paz si Dios quiere el acuerdo
entre Irán y Arabia Saudita será un buen
augurio para los árabes y el mundo
especialmente para los yemeníes para
poner fin a la guerra levantar el
bloqueo y pagar los salarios sin embargo
para muchos otros yemeníes lo pactado
por Arabia Saudita de Irán está lejos de
resolver la guerra en su país
No creo que las relaciones diplomáticas
entre arabias Saudita eran permitan
establecer una paz integral en la región
pueden permitir una tregua temporal pero
no evitarán la guerra y no conducirán a
una paz integral y duradera en yemen
el camino es largo para sacar a yemen
del conflicto que ha derivado en una de
las crisis humanitarias más graves del
mundo con cientos de miles de Muertos
millones de desplazados y un riesgo de
hambruna a gran escala a finales de 2022
la ONU aseguraba que 20 millones estaban
pasando hambre y sufrían de desnutrición
de una población total de poco más de 30
millones